dans le monde 2 ou d'opi les humains
n'ont jamais existé
ce qui fait 2 août au pire un endroit
moderne civilisé est entièrement animal
voici un animal les animaux 2 août au
pis son entrepôt more fun c'est un mot
très sophistiqué qui signifie que ces
animaux marcher sur deux pattes qui ne
se promènent pas tout nu
merci enfin voila c'est mieux et qu'ils
utilisent la technologie
on trouve des mammifères du monde entier
ajoute qu des gros du côté des rapides
des lampes
mais ne croyez pas que c'est un monde
parfait les habitants ne vivent pas tous
en bonne intelligence
il ya comme chez nous des ennemis
naturels ce qui engendre quelques
problèmes mais la nature d'autres les
animaux de qualité qui leur permettent
de survivre quand certains possèdent une
vision nocturne hors norme
d'autres ont une ouïe est incroyablement
développer et à un pistolet
tranquillisants très puissante
voilà vous êtes prévenus zutopi vous
n'aurez jamais rien vu d'aussi et
poilant